okay thanks so some of you have been
asking what happened to your facial hair
Ryan it's at the end of Movember
actually I was hearing all this talk
about shaving Polliwogs and so on and
let's just say I was inspired okay so in
this talk I have shaved and I will be
shaving off super pollywog factors for
the orthogonal vectors problem ok I
won't cover all pair shortest paths in
this talk to even get through the
orthogonal vectors problem will take
some time but I hope to show you sort of
the randomized algorithm for orthogonal
vectors and then motivate how the you
get addie randomization I'll just oven
okay so this is joint work with Timothy
Chan to appear in soda now the
orthogonal vectors problem I by now
you've seen it several times I think
we're given in boolean vectors and D
dimensions we all know if there's a pair
whose inner product is 0 over the
integers okay so so this has been the
conjecture that this is hard and has
been used to prove things actually
algorithms for it also have applications
and a previous paper with a mere abuddin
watching you show some of these
applications now the the trivial
algorithm for final vectors just tries
all in squared peers and takes their
inner product takes in squared times D
time now there have been some minor
improvements for example gum and lipton
showed in 2001 that you can in fact if
the dimension is large you can in fact
solve it in time n squared times D to
the sea point 373 so this is matrix
mobile occasion exponent minus 2 okay so
so the dimension is really large you can
solve it faster than squared times D so
let me just give like a really quick
demonstration of how you do that so the
idea is you write the so-called Graham
matrix of the
set of vectors so like imagine writing
down rose each row is a vector columns
each column this vector so it's the
matrix in its transpose when you
multiply them you get this matrix of N
squared entries and clearly reading this
off will tell you if there's an
orthogonal pair or not and the point is
when you can use fast matrix
multiplication at this matrix
publication okay so this is where you
would get something like this you can do
better if you use more customized
rectangular matrix motel ger iffens
however any algorithm which does this
kind of thing is obviously going to take
at least n squared time because it is
effectively just computing the inner
products okay we would like to solve it
faster than square time be done very
fast wendys yeah you can ya hear yeah
you can you can yes well I mean yes but
for arbitrary d yeah yeah so no you
could you can definitely plug in
rectangular matrix mall I'll rhythms and
do faster okay yeah the point is though
any such approach will is effectively
computing all the inner products so when
you would like to do something faster
than squared okay and why would we like
to do something fascinating squared well
for one it's known that the strong
essential time I pause this implies you
cannot solve it faster than squared time
and what I mean by this is that it says
if we assume strong EDH then for all
epsilon we're throwing liquors isn't in
into the two minus epsilon even times
two little o of the time so like even
sort of sub exponential factors in D you
still cannot get into the one point nine
nine nine nine nine time assuming strong
th ok and be when I first proved this I
thought this was a road to like getting
a CNF SAT algorithm so so so my quest
was to try to get actual faster
algorithm now recently with a mirror and
watching we did get a faster worth on
the doctors algorithm but it it seemed
inherently require rounds so this the
running time is a maybe a bit tricky to
unfold all right the exponent is like
one over order log of D over log in now
it's much easier to think of D the
dimension as some constant times log in
ok so that's just one over order log
constant ok so a corollary of this
algorithm is that for all constants C
there is an epsilon so if you want to
solve orthogonal vectors with C log n
dimensions that will you can do that in
randomized into the two minus epsilon
time ok now the the case of C log n
dimensions is where it becomes
interesting for see greater than 1
because it's a dimension is like you
know login or less you could just brute
force me right like there's only two to
the D possible vectors say on one side
so you could have some table lookup
there so the problem really becomes
interesting when c is greater than one
and then then it becomes less clear what
you can do ok so one more note I want to
make about prior work is it you can swap
the quantifiers here so say there exists
a universal epsilon so for all constant
C orthogonal vectors with C log in
dimensions isn't in the two minus
epsilon time then strong eth would be
false and that more or less follows from
from this part here right if if no
matter what dimensionality you had
constant times log in you could always
get in the 1.9 then actually the case
that we care about here is the case
where d is some arbitrary constant times
log n that's what we need to refute
strange all right
so in this work we give we're foggle
vectors in deterministic same amount of
time so
so it's not exactly the same amount of
time there is a different constant in
the Big O here but I mean but sort of
morally speaking the same kind of
corollary holds and in other corollaries
along these lines would hold that you
get truly sub quadratic time when you
have you know some logarithmic amount of
dimensions okay that's one of our main
results another result is that the all
pair shortest path problem in EndNote
graphs is in deterministic in cubed over
two to the Omega square root log n time
so previously we had a randomized
algorithm they ran in this much time and
we can get a deterministic one here
again interesting because both of these
seem to critically require an honest and
their construction we can also get some
new results about Casey and s so for
example if you want to count the number
of satisfying assignments to a case e
and f let's say you've got invariable
Casey and F's then we can do that in
time two to the N times one minus one
over border k okay deterministically and
previously they were randomized
algorithms known for this but not a
deterministic one this is interesting
because up to this big o factor it
actually matches what you can do to just
solve case that period so the best-known
talons for just solving case that have
this sort of behavior and here we can
actually count the number of satisfying
assignments and get roughly the same
kind of behavior as a function of okay
all right so this is the feeling results
and well I will focus on in this talk is
solving orthogonal vectors
so first I'll give you the randomized
algorithm rovi and then I'll start
talking about the terminus together
that's the that's my plan okay because
yeah I was trying to think how could I
motivate this deterministic algorithm
without seeing the randomized one and I
just couldn't do it so so i'm going to i
don't have to give you the randomizer in
at least some form but before like the
deterministic one will make sense i
think all right okay so I like circuits
so the first thing I'm going to do think
about orthogonal vectors I'm going to
turn it into a circuit evaluation
problem ok so the orthogonal vectors
problem is really equivalent to
evaluating the following circuit ok so
I've got these vectors what I want to
evaluate is an or overall in choose two
pairs of vectors and I want to take an
and over all components of the vectors
aldi components of the vectors and let's
say let's say I've chosen the pair IJ on
this wire and here I've chosen the
component k ranging from 1 to d and at
the bottom I'm going to take the
negation of VI vacays component of VI
and the the Jade's component ok all
right so what this is saying is that
right so this thing is going to evaluate
to true if I there exists a pair IJ so
therefore all components in those two
vectors I and J at least one of the
components is 0 among the two right so
if at least one of the component 0 then
we'll have orthogonality if it's over
all the all the components okay so this
so this thing in other words this thing
is going to output 1 if and only if
yeah I v VJ we're talking ok so we're so
we're you know this we're just like
testing for for all the pairs if at
least one of them is going to be your
thought all right good so we want to
evaluate this kind of circuit it's very
it's a very nice looking circuit it's a
c0 depth three so what we're going to do
is so the main idea is to try to convert
this circuit let me call it something so
like four vectors of four n vectors i'll
call it Oh sub in ok that for that
second ok so I want to convert oh so
then into some polynomial representation
and then evaluate the polynomial using
some algebraic techniques that's that's
the idea and the algebraic techniques
that I'm going to use we originally
developed for proving lower bounds
against such kinds of circuits they were
used to sort of show that given constant
depth circuits of this form you can
always represent them in some
approximate way by some low degree
polynomial and oops here are some things
which can't be represented by low degree
polynomials so these circuits can't
compute these these other functions okay
but here we're going to use in a very
positive way that in where once i get
the polynomial i think if it is some
object i can manipulate to try to get
the answer try evaluate this thing
faster okay so actually can it can you
and everyone like to see what i wrote
down here oh there is there is that I
understand some people don't like on
your TV's but okay okay good all right
so the key trick you nobody can read my
handwriting okay good so he can I can
read ninety percent and recover the
wrist oh icic yeah I'll try to write in
some redundant error correcting code for
idea that I probably will make it less
legible but ok so the key trick is
actually so what part can't you read oh
this is fine okay no no okay if I so the
key trick no I won't take the bait not
this time okay so is uh so you've got a
big or all right let's say it's over
some variables or maybe subcircuits
itself y 1 through YT and we want to
smell represent this as a low degree
polynomial that that was the idea of
whisper off for us it will give us some
nice representation of the source of it
so if we just take the or function as is
and we try to represent it as a
polynomial it will have high degree it
will have degree
t too high for us what we want to do is
get some randomized representation of
this orb which has a lower degree so
we'll have some randomized reduction
okay and it's going to work with
probability at least say one minus one
over to the k k is some parameter mean k
is some sort of thing kind of
representation to you won't advise not a
rebus things you just add up I want you
I want you I key and ask if it's bigger
that's a footnote yeah so so you can
certainly you can certainly get a
nonzero polymer representation by adding
things up over the images so I'm gonna
get representation over the field of two
elements F to thank you yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and maybe it's not clear right
now why I would want that but hang tight
okay yeah integers or integers are good
for non zero things but like when you
want to compute things like and then it
becomes trickier yeah okay yeah so let's
just okay let's just say F we want F
some f two polynomial so a polynomial
over the field two elements okay okay so
so so what we're going to do is take an
oar over k different things and these
different things are just random X
source of the y 1 through YT so I have
okay different X source or parodies and
here I'm just going to pick a wire to be
present between say this XOR and the
save why so by with probability 1 hat so
I'm really just picking a random subset
of the bits taking the X or another
random subset X or and so on okay so I
mean this trick comes up in a lot of
context there's okay let's call this
gadget g all right so so I'm just taking
or replacing with an a small or thing of
K is much smaller than T I've random X
source now there are two things to think
about here
suppose the oars of the Y is 0 okay then
G is always going to be 0 okay so so
suppose I have so like now take some
fixed y 1 through I t-shirt bits if
there or a zero all these X ours will be
0 sort of thing well but 0 yeah on the
other hand if it's one then I want to
say that this thing is 1 with
probability at least one minus one over
to the K so what's the idea here well
for each of these separate X oars if the
or here if there's at least one which is
1 then the probability i picked an odd
cardinality subset of those with your
one is one-half ok and in that case this
thing will fire when the whole thing
will be one now that's independently
with properly half each time I have some
error if if any one of them work ok and
they will properly you know a half then
it will i'll put the whole thing without
put one ok so we so the probability that
all of them fail is one into the k
probably all of them you know output
zero despite the fact that or is one is
one into decay so probably this thing is
the right answer 1 is 1 minus that ok ok
so so this is sort of the key trick used
here and the point is when i when i
write this is an f2 polynomial I get
something of degree K as a and K is just
some parameter i can set so all right
this is a polymer we have to write x or
parody that's just addition over f2 and
though i can use de Morgan's laws to get
something which is a degree K here
alright so so that's the one trick you
use another trick just in general is
that like say you've got one of these
circuits and you've got something
negated as in here you can always write
that as one x or x of i right
is just another rule you can use to
convert a circuit to a polynomial you
can also say things like if I've got
like an or of a bunch of things I
convert that using de Morgan's laws to
1x or and of the same bunch of things
and each of these are X sword with one
hey this this is just by de Morgan's
laws I can convert an ore into an ad by
negating the top and negating the things
in at the end because this one x or a
variable access negation so doing that
right I start to get things which are
basically Paula knows over f2 because
this is addition X horse addition over
f2 and and is multiplication so what I'm
going to do is just take this circuit
I've got apply this kind of this key
trick to these kinds of gates in some
appropriate way and then convert
everything to X or an X or an circuit
and eventually reach some polynomial
which has low degree and it's still
going to represent this circuit on any
particular input with high probability
so there's so that's like that's a
second thing the last thing that you
need the last sort of rule yeah this
kind is just distributivity now I'm
going to write it out in circuit form
that's what it's clear so the
distributive all ok that's a
multiplication of sums right we get in
some okay to the T multiplications of
tea
yeah this is this is just the
distributive law but that's useful too
because this says that given any circuit
may of X oars and Anne's I can always
turn into some kind of big X or of n
circuit the sum of monomials that's what
we already know about polynomials but
just written in in circuit language okay
okay so using these rules you can from
this Oh sub and get an F 2 polynomial or
this event and so I'll just state the
proposition that we get in the interest
of time like sort of if you take this
this trick this trick this trick in this
trick and combine them and play with the
parameters you will obtain the following
I have confidence in all of you ok so
the proposition is you can randomly
reduce the circuit for orthogonal
vectors to an f2 polynomial let's call
it let's call it P with and say Polly n
the times n juice order log.d monomials
ok such that so it's a randomized
reduction so I'm taking this Oh sub in
and I'm throwing in this you know trick
somewhere in my constructions to them
using some randomness so the randomized
production is the following property for
all inputs to the orthogonal vectors
problem let's say sets of vectors V sub
I I ranging from 1 to n we get we get
the probability over a random polynomial
that also been on the set of vectors
equals the polynomial on the set of
vectors
this is probably a let's say is at least
3 / 4 just needs to be some constant
greater than 2 for our purposes so what
we're saying is you have this circuit
that will compute it will solve our thaw
vectors we're going to get some
polynomial with what looks like a really
large number of monomials and it will
run in this much time to construct that
thing proportional Romano wheels and it
will have this property that no matter
what input I want to evaluate it on I'll
have some three-fourths probably
actually outputting the right answer now
suppose you want to just directly use
this to solve our thumb vectors it will
look really silly in fact I think I
discovered this like in 2010 and then I
laughed and then I went on to do
something else because because like if
you you are into the inches order log
and this is sorry inches order log D
this is in the order log D ok we write
we're looking at the case where D is
order log in so that's end of the log
log in that's not too good if you want
to be 10 squared right like you want to
do a little bit better than that so so
it looks like this kind of thing is just
it's completely useless like why would
you even bother like I could easily
start with this thing do something like
what Mikeal is suggesting and get some
you know are good at least get like N
squared times to 2d or something right
like these get something polynomial ok
and and then so it looks like this thing
is useless totally useless however you
can in this is in fact the key to the to
the entire thing that that you can get
something which has not so bad
dependence on d and ok so let me try to
motivate how this is useful
there any questions while I'm a reason
they're just bewildered
okay to this bound of n choose oh lordy
yeah hey properties of onr is just the
site and you just it just uses the fact
that the polynomial istic can has degree
order log n or log d that's it yeah yeah
so like you get a low degree polynomial
namely one of order log D degree and so
you get so you get this mini yeah so uh
do you want me to sketch like at a very
high level how this works or you would
like for me to proceed because I got
like 15 minutes okay all right so it
looks something something like that and
my god how we're going to use it it's
like you know super polynomial looks
silly okay here's the algorithm so what
we're going to do so we start with n
vectors the first step is to divide the
set of vectors into in over s grips
let's say order in over s groups of s
vectors each just approximately
up to s vectors each all right just an S
here is some parameter yes is going to
be some special parameter we will set
and we want to maximize this parameter
in the end if you get the best possible
algorithm we can okay so the second step
is ok for all pairs of groups I know
there are n over s squared of these
we're going to evaluate Oh sub s okay on
the union of the two groups I mean
technically it is like two inspectors
there so k and most 2s all right so I'm
going to take a so maybe but draw a
picture be easier so I take have in
vectors and D dimensions I partition
them up into groups of size s okay there
n over s such box for every pair of
blocks I want to evaluate your thought
I'm going to solve the orthogonal
vectors problem on that block and
they're the most to s vectors in that
block that's what I want to do that's
that's the JDM i'm going to use this
pawn representation to do that okay the
third step is well okay if any call to
this this evaluation Oracle outputs one
then return orthogonal pair otherwise no
else no beer
okay we're just we're just going through
all the pairs of groups and seeing if
you lose your sorrow vector among those
pairs okay 3s1 there'll be some you know
to be some pair of groups where is there
okay so that's one and three are
perfectly clear I hope now how do we do
step two right our goal will be to do
step two to choose s and use this pollen
else's we can do step two in about Oh
tilde n squared over s squared time
that's our goal okay the first step very
easy fast thur step very easy fast this
is a hard step we want to set s the
parameter and use this polynomial such
that we can do this evaluation and
essentially o tilde one amortize time
per group that's what we want Oh tilde
one amortize time per pair of group okay
all right so let's break down a step 2
into 2 parts so to a now we're just
going to try to use this this polymer
from the proposition here so we're going
to because there's some chance of error
right there's like 14 chance of beer
we're going to create a bunch of
polynomial the 10 log impala know so
that so that we can amplify our
probabilities access' over there so for
about 10 log n independent trials we
will randomly reduce the sub s 2
polynomials p1 through PT okay by the
proposition we want to do right now
these are polynomials that are working
that were right what / where n has
become s so we got aunt s there and s
there okay so this number of monomials
is like as to the older lagdi roughly
the best the parameter we can sit right
that's the important part so that's the
first part now to be okay so for all
these trials 1 through t
we're going to evaluate piece of eye on
all in s squared pairs of groups that's
what we want to do right and here we're
going to use some lemma that I can only
sort of tell you as a black box some
rectangular matrix multiplication base
lemma all right i'll write this lemma
over here the limit basically says that
if i have if i have a set of points
which can be seen as a cartesian product
of two smaller sets of points and i want
to evaluate the polynomial over that
that polymer doesn't have too many
monomials okay I can control monomials
you then I can evaluate this polynomial
O of 1 amortize time and basically 0
total number of points fine let me just
say formally what the limit is make sure
ok so we're given sets a and B and let's
say they're in EM dimensions so these
will be inputs to my polynomial the
sizes of the two sets let's say capital
n I want to distinguish between the ends
here ok so then if we're given a
polynomial let's say over any field so
like FP over prime field FP p with let's
say it has that most capital into the
point 1 monomials so it has a number of
monomials smaller than a number of
points you want to evaluate it over like
so we're going to actually evaluate over
a cross B so it's some pollo a smaller
number of points we want but it's not
too much smaller ok ooh am I going to
okay can we can evaluate P on all points
in a cross B and
Oh Tilda capital N squared plus this
extra little vector capital in 1.1 times
M time okay sorry if this is not visible
there so but it is on the TV screen okay
so sorry so naively okay if we're we've
we've got capital N squared points to
dive 8 on we got Kaplan the point where
monomials naively it would take like
given this and given this size it will
take capital in the 2.1 time okay we are
removing the end of the point 1 the
Catalan point that is the savings very
good okay so it like naively if you have
some object of this size and you're
going to evaluate it on n squared points
it will take this much time but we do
something faster okay here and it's
something negligible it's like the
number of inputs to the to the
polynomial here ok so this capital n
square the doctor all right so okay so
for us what are we going to do we want
to set capital n to be little in over s
right and we're going to set em to B to
D times s okay because there are s of
vectors actually we get let's say if
we're taking the union of two groups to
s so there's like s vectors from one
group s vectors from the other group we
took the pair there's D dimensions in
both of them okay so that's like deep so
there's like a right like we've got v12
vs and like w12 WS these are the inputs
to our polynomial right each of them
have D bits so okay so that's a number
of inputs to the palm ok so what happens
when we plug this thing in here
you see racist
we have some bound number of monomials
and we can apply the limit to our
polynomial is provided the number of
monomials the most capital in the point
one okay so what we want is so our
number of monomials number of monomials
in some p sub i is a polynomial in SD
because I so know Oh sub s times s
choose order log D and we want that to
be less than capital n to the point one
and four US Capitol anise and over s so
this is what we want so provided we set
so we're going to set s such that this
inequality holds all right so if we set
s to be let's say some constant times
into the one over some constant times
log in right is order 1 factor then this
equality is satisfied for example now
but if you sort of work a little harder
you can actually have an exponent like
this maybe if you just sort of go
through what the choose function is
going to do to these things so what does
this say it says if we set our parameter
has to be this then we can execute the
step 2 in this much time Oh till the N
squared over s squared time and so our
savings over N squared is this squared
so our final run time
is Oh tilde n squared over s squared
which is most n squared minus this order
1 over log B and and I sort of promised
you that if you put a login factor this
this thing still holds it's just some
like one line like using Sterling's
inequality in the right way and so okay
alright so that's the randomized
algorithm and now I have four minutes to
tell you about the deterministic one is
expected okay so so how do we do
randomized this thing so the thing is it
looks really really randomized okay so
so how do you you analyze a thing like
we're using this we're using this trick
okay actually the only randomized part
and this entire thing is this trick and
what was the trick because I erased it
so the trick was if you have a
collection of variables say why 12 IT
then I throw or as one then we can think
of the trick in the following way so if
you take a random vector of T bits okay
you take the inner product of that
vector with your vector Y so thinking of
the variables here as just some vector
then we're looking at the chance that
this is one mod two okay and we're set
and we said that this is one half so if
you start with some variables whose or
is one theory interpreting will give you
zero month too okay so with probability
one you'll have 0 mod 2 on the other
hand if the or is one if there's some
subset which happens to have ones in it
when I take the inner product with a
random vector I will get something odd
with probably have okay this is just a
restatement of the trick that said
before but it's useful to sort of say it
like this because then it begins to look
like something which for which you have
small sample spaces ok all right ok so
the first thing to do is to try to get a
small sample space for this thing rather
than taking you know something overall
to the t possible random vectors it
would be really nice to have a small set
of vectors for which we can get roughly
the same kind of behavior ok and this
was developed by a aura noir in 93 and
they called it an epsilon by a set okay
so the definition so you take some
subset of 0 1 2 T here so some subset of
this thing we say it's epsilon biased if
for all vectors why your tea bits and
which are not the LZ Rose vector the
probability when I pick a random vector
over this set and take this inner
product the probability that I get one
mod two okay it won't be exactly a half
but we pretty close it'll be in the
interval half minus epsilon half plus
epsilon so this is so the idea to do
give some relaxed definition of the
guarantee we want
and hopefully get a much smaller set
than to the T in fact you can get a
really small set so they showed in fact
you can construct s let's say where s
has size polynomial in t + 1 over
epsilon in polynomial and T and over
epsilon time okay so so you can get a
very small sample space for this thing
all right and there's one more
ingredient but I think I'm running out
of time but i'll tell you the ingredient
at least so and then you can read the
paper so the idea is that we're going to
sum over everything in some epsilon by a
set okay and it's not too big compared
it was not to the tea-things it's some
polynomial and tea and some one over
epsilon things we have some error here
though and what we want to do is we're
actually going to count the number of
our thug inul vectors so in fact our are
deterministic algun will count the
number with long of vectors what we want
to do this is we want to convert this
probability into a sum over vectors and
then we want to tally up the number of
times that the sum is odd versus even
tally up this number make our error just
small enough so that we can actually
distinguish between like having n minus
1 orthogonal vectors and in orthogonal
vectors okay but how are we going to do
that so like we just start summing
everything up we'll just get kind of
gigantic like things it's not even clear
like what how we could some a bunch of
month two things well it turns out
there's something in complexity theory
which will do exactly that for you so so
let's see so this is due to yell so we
say that the polynomial over the
integers is l mod amplifying
if for all Y over the integers if Y is
congruent to 1 mod 2 then when i run it
through this polynomial is congruent to
1 mod 2 to the l and if it's 0 mod 2
then when i run it through this
polynomial it's going to go into 0 mod
to the l ok so at a very very high level
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take on these polynomials in fact making
me made to have degree about to L minus
1 ok I'm going to take one of these
finals where l is about order log s for
me and so basically so that this to the
L is like much bigger than whatever i'm
coming up so let you know some some log
and like n and d & s all together and
then using this if i take these various
sums that i'm thinking from the trick
and apply the small amplifying plan on
turning each time i can count exactly
the number of times that something is
odd exactly what I'm something it's even
ok and using that I can distinguish
between whenever a pair is orthogonal in
which case like everything will just be
0 you will just have 0 mod to all the
time so like the probability whenever
line this interval just be 0 and when
it's not our struggle and this sort of
event will happen you know roughly half
the time so it's a composition of this
polynomial and that construction and you
end up getting your end up getting a
number of monomials it says the that
satisfies exactly the same down actually
ok i need to stop here thanks
sorry tomorrow I understand why not just
be there so you have your flocks of a
spectrum yeah on every pair yeah yeah
that I have a polymer for like the whole
group like the whole group check every
pair right so yeah so like for a
specific group when I'm feeding into
this polynomial is all the vectors from
that group oh all the vectors from that
group all s vectors from that group LSD
dimensional vectors from the group then
these limits us dead about people
winning product yeah that's actually
fringing on the big groups then uh yeah
I mean it's saying yeah yeah so it's
evaluating in this polynomial over all
pairs of groups yeah yeah yeah so like
everything in the group so we have some
pong which is evaluating vectors in bulk
yeah sort of s vectors in book and we
just set s so that this can actually be
done still efficiently yeah degree oh
that does that somehow enter in the
intron in time you get is it Yeah Yeah
right there babe yeah yeah it does it in
more or less interest like they're okay
yeah yeah yeah and but it turns out to
be like we up to Big O factors the same
it does it's sort of said I would think
that you maybe get some loss going this
way like you're doing strictly more than
your before but no it is it's at up to
Big O factors there is to say yes
any other questions all right so let's
take damage